You know,
uh,
when I was in high school,
well not high school,
I guess it was in a great school.
So what does 11 what grade is that?
Depends on how smart you are.
Really.
Fifth Grade.
Yeah.
Depends on how smart you are.
You know what I was reading his out crate.
Ronan Farrow,
you know Woody Allen and I'm the guy wrote that article.
Yeah.
He's not really woody Allen's kid.
By the way.
Look at that kid.
Look at Frank Sinatra.
Holla at your boy.
Hello Joe.
Boy,
that kid is Frank Sinatra's kid.
One thousand one million percent.
Cause me and Farrell used to bang Frank Sinatra.
Oh really?
They had a freak.
Look,
I know.
come on.
Get the fuck Outta here.
Look at it.
First of all,
handsome men.
That Ronan Farrow handsome man.
Yeah,
that is God dammit.
That is frank fucking Sinatra's kid.
1 billion trillion percent.
You better stay the fuck away from 23 and me cause they'll out that.
Yeah,
look at that one and route 23 in meal.
Just send back the song.
New York,
New York when he was 11.
This,
how smart this guy is.
When he was 11 he was taking college courses.
Oh my God.
11 nerd alert.
That's what I read.
Makes sure that's true.
I don't want to,
I don't want to write an article about me.
It's a bit of bad information,
but so they had a freak relationship anyway when they were together.
That was their only biological kid and it's not really their biological kid.
Why not?
Because it's fucking Frank Sinatra's kid.
Sarah was started college at age 11 wow.
He says he fell apart while pursuing the Harvey Weinstein Story.
Whoa.
What do you mean he fell apart?
Probably because it was so dark.
Oh saying,
come on man.
Do you remember before that story came out,
everybody knew that guy was a creep.
Right.
But it was like this thing about like,
like more door,
you know,
like he lives,
lived in Soran lives under the rock somewhere.
Everybody knew he was a creep.
You,
everybody had heard stories,
but this guy,
he graduated at 15 from college.
Oh my God.
Why does it keeps saying the son of Mia Farrow and Woody Allen?
It should say wink,
wink,
nudge,
nudge.
But that's crazy though.
They're trying to push that so much.
You know this son of Mia Farrow and Woody Allen?
Well he was raised by them for a little while until what?
He started banging his sister.
I'm like,
God,
yeah,
that's a freak household.
And then they're out here.
Hollywood's got the darkest arts,
Bro.
They lived in New York.
Well even New York.
Hollywood.
Cause some of it's the same thing.
New York,
Hollywood,
Hollywood is just show business.
Yeah,
show business.
That's what I mean.
Well there's definitely something to that cause how about that composer that
turned out to be even more of a fucking asshole than Harvey Weinstein.
This is one composer that was just fucking all these young boys and if you
didn't fuck him and they just,
they recently got rid of him,
but he was just running things through sex and you know,
he just basically had a sex cult going on.
Find out who the fuck that guy was.
But he was a cherished,
famous loved composer.
And it turned out this,
this dude was just running the freak show behind the sturdy,
just not just being dirty,
but that was the way to get in and if this guy shut you down,
you were shut down forever.
You weren't working anymore.